ces acteurs sont américains le
réalisateur et britanniques son film
précédent s'intitulait sammy et rosie
s'envoient en l'air ce qui est nettement
moins élégant que les liaisons
dangereuses le chef-d'oeuvre de
choderlos de laclos mis cette fois au
goût anglo saxons nicole lecornu
langlois et alain ont rencontré la
marquise de merteuil alias denglos
favorite
les navires la 15 ans je possédais déjà
les talents aucun la plus grande partie
de nos politiques doivent leur
réputation semaine
il est surprenant tant les personnages
et de 200 ans soit toujours aussi vive
ange controversé mêmes rites aux
rencontres insolites entre un roman
épistolaire du xviiie siècle est une
star hollywoodienne mais déjà des
actrices comme jeanne moreau au cinéma
où caroline cellier au théâtre avait été
séduite par ce chef-d'oeuvre de la
perversion amoureuse et maintenant glenn
close
madame de merteuil
le canard de se tester
à ixelles je crois que l'un des grands
attraits de ses personnages et d'avoir
cette magnifique apparence si riche si
puissante et si contrôler
c'est l'histoire d'une grande passion
mme djibo forêt ddaf m
sa visite est demandé
la monuc a deux passions
elle est aussi je crois une grande
romantique jours c'est une belle
histoire d'amour qui font mal
une histoire machiavélique aussi devenu
grâce à stephen fry ce un film subtil
astucieux brillantissime